Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an Indian survival drama film
called “Trapped”. Watch out and take care!
Shaurya is a call centre employee living in
Mumbai, India. He has had a crush on his
co-worker Noorie for a long time. One day,
he gathers enough courage to call her but is too
shy to express his feelings. But starting that
day, he calls her daily and engages in an awkward
conversation that Noorie seems to enjoy. She loves
to flirt with Shaurya and get him nervous but is
annoyed at the fact that he never asks her out.
When he calls her the next time she asks him
to guess her favourite food in five seconds.
If he guesses right she will go
out with him but if it is wrong,
she will stop picking up his calls. Although
nervous, Shaurya guesses it correctly and lands
a date with her. That evening, they go to a street
vendor to eat her favourite food. Sometime later,
they are in a restaurant talking about different
things when Noorie casually mentions that she is
getting married in two months. A surprised Shaurya
asks her if her marriage has been arranged by her
parents. When she affirms he continues
the conversation, ignoring the topic.
That day marks the beginning of their friendship.
Noorie starts to look forward to meeting him and
hardly pays attention to work. They go on several
dates and start falling in love with each other.
One day, Shaurya brings her to his apartment
that he shares with three of his roommates.
They lock themselves in his room and start making
out. Noorie stops abruptly and is visibly upset
thinking about their future. Shaurya asks her to
cancel the wedding and elope with him. At first,
she thinks he is joking but starts to consider
it when he insists. When she says that she cannot
live with his roommate, he promises to find a
new apartment by tomorrow and move in with her.
Her wedding is in only two days so they will
have to be quick. Right after she leaves,
Shaurya calls several dealers to look for an
appropriate apartment. However, because of the
timing and low budget, he doesn’t get any.
He spends the entire day visiting apartment
complexes with little to no progress. In one of
such meetings, a stranger hears him talk about
wanting an affordable place. He approaches Shrauya
saying that he has a perfect place for him.
Shaurya is skeptical at first but he agrees to
come to have a look at the apartment anyway.
He is brought to a newly built high-rise apartment
complex that seems to be way more expensive than
what he can afford. He is told that the complex
was built two years ago but is empty due to
construction and legal issues. The apartment
that he is being offered belongs to a man who
hardly ever comes to that place. The stranger
he just met is only a caretaker of the place
but since the owner has been absent for two
years, he is unethically handing it to Shaurya
for money. The couple will be the only
people living in the massive building
which unsettles Shaurya. But when he gets a
look at the apartment, he forgets about all the
sketchy things related to it. It is massive with
a bedroom, a kitchen, a living area, a bathroom,
and a fenced balcony. The place is clearly worth
way more than the price he is paying. He finalizes
the deal and gets the keys to the place. Following
that, he packs up his luggage from his old place
but doesn't tell his roommates about his plans to
elope. He simply claims that he is going home for
a few days and leaves. At his new apartment, he
lays down a mattress, cleans the room a little,
and falls asleep, hoping to surprise Noorie the
next day. He has put his phone to charge but the
power cuts off. The following morning, he wakes
up late and quickly does his morning routine. He
further notices that none of the taps are working
and uses bottled water to brush his teeth.
After some minutes he finally steps out
of the apartment and locks it. However,
he has to run inside again to get his phone. He
forgets to get the keys and accidentally locks
himself inside. Noorie calls him and asks him why
he is late. Shaurya explains that he will be there
in a few minutes but doesn’t tell her where he
is to keep it a surprise. When the call ends
and he tries to get out, he realises that he is
in trouble. He forcefully tries to open the lock
but fails. He finds some tools in the drawers and
uses them but without the keys, opening it seems
almost impossible. Following that, he calls a
helpline asking them to send someone to break
the lock. But to his misfortune, his phone dies
before he can tell them the address. He tries to
charge it again but the power outage only makes
it difficult. Shaurya gets more irritated with
time and starts to bang the door to break it but
is unsuccessful yet again. Moreover, he hurts his
hand in the process. Moments later, he comes to
the balcony and calls the watchman who cannot hear
him because of the noise of the traffic and the
height. Shaurya finally registers that he is stuck
in the apartment. His plan to elope with
Noorie has failed because she will probably
think he has run away afraid of commitment.
He cleans the wound with the little bottled water
he has left. In hopes of charging his phone’s
battery, he keeps it out in the sun but it does
nothing. Following that, he continues shouting for
help. Hours pass but no one hears him. At night,
he eats a packet of biscuits and falls asleep.
When he wakes up the next morning, the power is
still out and the taps aren’t working either. He
yet again tries to open the door with everything
he has in the house. Even after throwing a chair
and a fan at it, it doesn’t budge. Shaurya is
now ready to take extreme measures to get out. He
unplugs the TV mounted on the wall and throws it
off the balcony. It lands below with a loud bang,
but the watchman still doesn’t notice it. Later,
he eats away all the biscuits and is left with
little to no water. He notices several pieces of
cardboard on top of the kitchen shelf and thinks
of a plan. Using his toothpaste, he writes “help”
and the name of the building on them and drops
it off the balcony. To his dismay, the cardboard
lands on someone’s roof where no one is going to
find it. Shaurya doesn’t lose hope and does the
same with another piece of cardboard that lands
on another building’s roof. When he runs out of
toothpaste, he uses his blood to write the message
and drops two more cardboards off the balcony. One
of them lands directly below the building while
the other one lands on someone’s terrace.
He stays on the balcony waiting for someone
to find them and look for him. In the evening,
a woman comes to the terrace to pick up clothes
that had been drying in the sun. Shaurya gets up
and starts yelling at her but is disappointed
when she doesn’t notice the cardboard.
At night he goes to the kitchen and sees that he
is completely out of food. He also notices a rat
on the floor and is terrified. While trying to
run away from it, he hits his head on the wall
and falls unconscious. The next morning he wakes
up still on the floor. He sees that the tap in
the kitchen sink is working but he is too scared
to go inside because of the rat. Soon, it runs
out of water and he is left disappointed. He had
broken his glasses last night that he fixes with a
pyjama string. In another attempt to make someone
see him, he builds a makeshift sling shot and uses
it to launch pebbles at the woman on the top of
the roof. The pebbles catch her attention but she
ignores them after seeing no one around. Another
day passes in a similar way. At night, Shaurya
uses his clothes to write help on the balcony’s
bar and starts banging the bars with a pan. He
does it till the morning but no one hears him. The
watchman finally finds the cardboard he had thrown
but the guy cannot read so he ignores it.
Later, the woman from the nearby house also finds
the cardboard. She looks around but cannot see
Shaurya from that height. He yells for help trying
to get her attention and is overjoyed when he sees
her coming to the apartment complex. The woman
asks the watchman if anyone stays there. The man
claims that he has worked there for two years and
is sure no one is in the building. The woman is
still not satisfied so she goes up several floors.
However, the empty place spooks her out so she
returns home. Shaurya sees her leaving and loses
the speck of hope he had. When it turns dark,
he burns the clothes that were hung in the bars.
When that starts to blow out, he also lights
the mattress on fire. He jumps up and down,
sure that the fire is bound to get someone’s
attention. However, the plan goes wrong when
the fire spreads to a couch. He somehow blows it
out with his vest and falls asleep. Out of hunger,
he dreams of eating his favourite meal with Noorie
like they used to. He also remembers the survival
shows that teach to eat anything one gets when
they are deserted. Taking the advice, he goes
to the kitchen to kill the rat but freaks out when
it runs towards him. The next day, thirst gets the
best of him. So, he reluctantly pees on the pan
and drinks it. However, the taste makes him vomit
right after. He spends the entire day sleeping and
wakes up the next morning to heavy rainfall.
Shaurya quickly collects water in the pan and
drinks from it. He also uses everything that is
a container to collect as much water as he
can, including the fridge, the flush tank,
and the paint cans. The next morning, a pigeon
lands on the balcony. With his only chance,
Shaurya uses the slingshot to kill it and use
it as food. However, when he tries to skin it,
he is disgusted. A flashback shows us the
time he and Noorie were out on a date.
Shaurya, who has been a vegetarian his entire
life argues that killing helpless animals for food
is unethical. Back in the present, he reluctantly
cuts the bird’s head off and roasts it. He also
gets over his fear of rats and manages to trap it.
When the isolation takes the best of him, he talks
to the rat about all the ways he can escape. He
has seen that an apartment some floors below him
doesn’t have bars on the balcony. If he manages
to get to the apartment and the door is open,
he could walk right out of it. However, for that,
he has to cut the bars off his balcony first.
The only tool he has is a metal sheet but he
starts sawing it anyway. Several days pass
but he doesn’t give up trying to cut it. He feeds
on ants, cockroaches, and occasional birds. When
things get tough, he starts to miss little things
he used to dread like getting pushed by sweaty
people on the bus. After many days of sawing,
and burning the railing, it finally breaks.
Shaurya takes the chance and carefully climbs down
the bars of three floors. When he finally gets to
the one with no bars, his legs are too short to
climb in. He uses his belt for support and finally
gets inside it. With much courage, he pulls the
door to the apartment and is overjoyed when it
happens to be open. He climbs down the stairs
and finally makes eye contact with the watchman.
He has a hundred things he wants to say to him but
he simply walks away. A week later, Noorie comes
to visit him in the hospital. She believed that he
had abandoned her and has already gotten married.
He tries to hold her hand but she moves it,
knowing that they cannot be together now.
Some days later, Shaurya returns to work but is
shattered to see that his friends and colleagues
had not even noticed his absence. Later that
day, he goes to his favourite restaurant and
enjoys his favourite food that he missed dearly.
In the last scene, he returns to the apartment
and looks at the broken bar.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.